donc on ne les voit pas souvent à faire
on ne les voit presque jamais les
célèbres que zac russe se manifeste
seulement quand l'heure est grave
symbole de force de vigilance et souvent
de répression et voilà contre toute
attente dans les rues enneigées
d'ekaterinbourg à la recherche de gens
qui renaît flou qui tous bons si les
gens ont l'air malade on les envoie à
l'hôpital dit le général major guinée
dit kovalev va pas trop le psy kozak
patrouille les quartiers de 1 mois sans
aucun mandat de la vie une mission
entièrement bénévole tontine cache pas
lasser cherchant surtout les asiatiques
dit il mais pas seulement les chinois
les viêt amiel et tadjik les kirghiz
parce que le virus vient de leur côté du
continent
il n'ya pourtant aucun cas déclarés
d'infection quand la virus en russie
pour le moment mais les cosaques ne
laisse rien au hasard
l'upr mots vous pouvez faire du
feuilleton peuvent que je me prenais ce
masque et faites attention il ya de
bonnes chances que les chinois soient
dans le magasin le virus est à nos
portes
les autorités russes ont d'ailleurs pris
des mesures exceptionnelles pour éviter
la contagion
la russie a non seulement fermer ses
quatre mille kilomètres de frontière
terrestre avec la chine
mais depuis le 21 février plus un seul
chinois n'a le droit de mettre le pied
au ping qu'ils soient touristes
travailleurs ou étudiants des centaines
d'étudiants sont partis célébrer le
nouvel an en chine et la plupart n'ont
pas le droit de revenir de cette
employée d'une cantine au grand marché
ce couple russe est venu faire des
enfants masqués au cours d'un vote soit
parce que nous avons pas que la
marchandise soit contaminé tous les deux
semblent avoir suivi à la lettre les
conseils des cosaques de la ville qui
profitent de leur tournée pour
distribuer des masques petit mot
ekatérinbourg ce sont les cosaques comme
vous voyez qu'ont pris les choses en
main dans votre cour des directives
officielles sont mis de la mairie qui
elles sont experts
car tous les chinois qui sont arrivés
dans la capitale avant l'interdiction
sont désormais traqués dans leur hôtel
et leur logement le maire prévient dans
un communiqué que des descentes
déplaisante mais nécessaires seront
effectués par des policiers des médecins
afin de placer les chinois en
quarantaine c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on
entend à l'échelle du pays
quand la demande cet homme que nous
avons croisé à ekatérinbourg passé douze
jours en isolement dans un sanatorium
parce qu'il rentrait de pique
des mesures jugées rcc selon la chine
qui dans cette lettre envoyée aux
autorités russes demandent l'arrêt du
profilage constant de ce ressortissant y
compris dans les transports publics ou
les chauffeurs auraient reçu la consigne
d'alerter les policiers
quentin asiatiques montent à bord de
leur véhicule et que dire de ces deux
animateurs populaire de tokyo russes qui
ont adapté une vieille chanson
soviétique pour chasser l'ennemi
[Musique]
zito quand la vie que ce que nous sommes
pas lâchés nous avons battu les nazis
nous allons vaincre seulement le vivre
peut-être mais à quel prix
en cause la conversion vidéo nous sommes
les cosaques nous sommes invincibles dit
gainey
mais l'économie elle en souffre aux
boucles en moyenne 15 millions de
dollars de pertes par jour pour la
russie et qui sait combien de temps ces
mesures absolument draconiennes pour
seront réglés
les secours à l'adar plus qu'intérêt